I will do reading and writing uh so I'll
I'm usually working on a book at any
given time uh or if you shut off the the
rest of the world yes so I put some
music in my ears usually Brahms or Bach
uh sometimes Beethoven or Mozart it's
those four those are on rotation no rap
no rap no rap despite my extraordinary
rendition of WAP yeah I'm not in fact
around you still do you still hate rap
um the song it's uh I will say I do not
think that it is the peak of Western
civilized art okay I I don't think that
100 years from now people will be gluing
their faces to a whap and protest at the
environment but uh Brahms and the rest
will be still around yes uh I would
assume if people still have a
functioning prefrontal cortex and any
sort of wrong words from Ben Shapiro all
right so you got some classical music in
your ears and you're focusing uh are you
at the computer when you're writing yeah
I'm I'm at the computer
um usually we have a kind of a room that
has some sun coming in so it's nice in
there or I'll go up to a library that we
just completed for me uh so I'll go up
there and I'll and I'll write and like
physical books uh yeah I love physical
books and because I because I keep
Sabbath I I don't use Kindle because
when I'm reading a book and I hit
Sabbath I have to turn off the Kindle so
that means that I have tons and tons and
tons of physical books when you move
from Los Angeles to Florida I had about
7 000 volumes I had a discard probably 4
000 of them
um and then I've built that back up now
so I'm probably gonna have to go through
another round where I put them somewhere
else I tend to tab books rather than
highlighting them because I can't
highlight on Sabbath so I have like the
little stickers and I put them in the
book so a typical book from me you can
see it on the book club will be like
filled with tabs on the side things that
I want to take now actually uh I got a
person who I I
um pay to go through and write down in
files the quotes that I've that I like
from the book so I have those handy
um so which is a good way for me to
remember what it is that I've that I've
read
because I I read probably
some routine three and five books a week
uh and then the uh in a good week five
uh and then I you know write I read and
then I go pick up my kids from school at
3 30. so according to my kids I have no
job there I'm there in the mornings
until they leave for school I pick them
up from school I hang out with them
until they go to bed which is usually 7
30 or so so I'm helping them with their
homework and I'm playing with them and
I'm taking them on rides in in the brand
new Tesla which my son is obsessed with
uh and uh and then I put them to bed and
then I sit back down I prep for the next
day go through all those media sources I
was talking about compile kind of a
schedule for what I want the show to
look like and and run a show it's very
detail-oriented nobody writes anything
for me I write all my own stuff
um so every word that comes out of my
mouth is my fault and uh and then you
know hopefully I have a couple hours to
or an hour to hang out with my wife uh
before before we go to the awards you
write do you edit a lot or does it just
come out you're thinking like what are
the key ideas I want to express uh no I
don't tend to edit a lot so I I thank
God I'm able to write extraordinarily
quickly so I write very very fast in
fact fact in a previous life I was you
also speak fast so similar yeah exactly
and I speak in paragraphs so it's it's
exactly the same thing uh in a previous
life I was a ghost writer so I used to
be sort of known as a turnaround
specialist in the publishing industry
and it'd be somebody who came to the
publisher and says I have three weeks
and to get this book done I don't have a
word done and they would call me up and
be like this person needs a book written
and so in three weeks I'd knock out
sixty thousand words or so is there
something you can say to the process
that you follow to think like how you
think about ideas like you stuff is
going on in the world
and trying to understand what is
happening what are the explanations what
are the forces behind this do you have a
process or or just uh you uh wait for
the Muse to give you the interpretation
I mean I think that it I don't think
it's a formal process but because I read
so there's two ways to do it one is
sometimes
you know that sometimes The Daily Grind
of the news is going to refer back to
core principles that are broader and
deeper
so I thank God because I've read so much
on so many different things of a lot of
different point of views
um then if if something breaks and a
piece of news breaks I can immediately
sort of channel that into in the mental
Rolodex these three big ideas that I
think are are really important and then
I can talk at length about what those
ideas are and I can explicate those uh
and and so you know for example when
we're talking about must taking over
Twitter before and I immediately go to
the history of media right that's that's
me tying it into a broader theme yeah uh
on you know and I do that I would say
fairly frequently what we're talking
about
um
say subsidization of industry and I can
immediately tie that into okay what's
the history of subsidization in the
United States going all the way back to
Woodrow Wilson and Ford through FDR's
industrial policy and how does that tie
into sort of broader Economic Policy
internationally so that it allows me to
tie into bigger themes because what I
tend to read is mostly not news what I
tend to read is mostly books
I would say most of my media diet is
actually not the stock like that's
that's the icing on the cake but the
actual cake is the hundreds of pages in
history econ
geography that that I'm that I'm social
science that I'm reading every week and
so that that sort of stuff allows me to
to think more deeply about these things
that's one way of doing the other way of
doing it is Russia breaks in the news I
don't know anything about Russia I
immediately go and I purchase five books
about Russia and I read all of them and
so one of the unfortunate things about
our uh our the fortunate thing for me
and the unfortunate thing about the
world is that if the unfortunate thing
about the world is you read two books on
a subject you are now considered by the
media an expert on this subject uh so
that's you know sad and shallow but that
is the way that it is the good news for
me is that my job isn't to be a full
expert on any of these subjects and I
don't claim to be right I'm not a Russia
expert I know enough on Russia to be
able to understand when people talk
about Russia what the system looks like
how it works and all of that and then to
explicate that for the common man which
a lot of people who are infused with the
expertise can't really do if you're so
deep in the weeds that you're like a
full-on academic expert on a thing
sometimes it's hard to translate that
over to a Master audience which is
really my job well I think it can
actually it's funny with the two books
you can actually
get a pretty deep understanding if you
read and also think deeply about it it
allows you to approach a thing from
first principles a lot a lot of times if
you're a quote-unquote expert you get um
you get carried away by the momentum of
what the the field has been thinking
about versus like stepping back all
right what is really going on the The
Challenge is to pick the right two books
right so that usually what I'll try to
find is somebody who knows the topic
pretty well and have them recommend or a
couple people and have them recommend
books so a couple years ago I knew
nothing about Bitcoin I was at a
conference and uh a couple of people who
you've had on your show actually uh were
there and I asked them give me your top
three books on bitcoin and so then I
went and I read like nine books on
bitcoin and so if you're nine books on
bitcoin you at least know enough to get
by yeah uh and so that so I can actually
explain what Bitcoin is and why it works
or why it doesn't work in some cases and
and what's happening in the markets that
way so that that's you know very very
helpful well Putin is an example that's
a difficult one to find the right books
on
I think the new Czar is the one I read
where was the most objective the one I
read I think about Putin was it was one
called strong man
it was very highly critical of of Putin
but it gave like a good background on
him yeah so I'm very skeptical sort of
things that are very uh they're critical
of Putin uh because it feels like
there's activism injected into the
history like the way the rise and fall
the Third Reich is written about Hitler
I like because there's almost not a
criticism of Hitler it's a description
of Hitler which is very
um it's easier to do about a historical
figure which with William Shire with the
rise and fall of the Third Reich it's
impressive because he lived through it
but it's very tough to find objective
descriptions about the history of the
man and a country of Putin of zelenski
of any difficult Trump was the same and
you I feel like everybody that's the
hero villain archetype right and it's
like either somebody's completely a hero
or completely a villain and the truth is
pretty much no one is completely a hero
or completely a villain people in fact
I'm not sure that I love descriptions of
people as heroes or villains generally I
think that people tend to do heroic
things or do villainous things in the
same way that I'm not sure I love
descriptions of people as a genius my
dad used to say this when I was growing
up he used to say they didn't believe
that there were Geniuses he said he
believed that there were people with a
genius for something because people you
know yes they're people who are very
high IQ and we call them Geniuses but
does that mean that they're good at EQ
stuff not necessarily but there are
people who are geniuses at EQ stuff in
other words it would be more specific to
say that somebody's a genius at
engineering than to say just broad
spectrum they're a genius and that does
avoid the problem of thinking that
they're good at something that they're
not good at right it's a little more
specific